[Музика]
Поцілунок доброго ранку. Я дуже радий
бачити тебе тут, у моєму класі, тому сьогодні
ми збираємося подорожувати, але ми збираємося
подорожувати, не виходячи з нашого крісла,
я знаю, що це завжди змушує нас  смійся,
коли ми почуємо, що Лондон — столиця
Великобританії, я сподіваюся, що це буде
не єдине, що ви пам'ятаєте з
запитів англійської мови, і ми збираємося
провести вихідні в Лондоні, ви знаєте, хто
ви, ті, хто планував цю подорож, тому
сідайте на борт нашого літака і давайте
спочатку послухаємо нашого капітана, тому ви повинні
послухати, що каже нам наш капітан,
і ви повинні заповнити пропуски
цифрами, ви почуєте цей
запис двічі,
так що готові послухати, але раніше  слухайте
, будь ласка, перегляньте весь
текст на всякий випадок, щоб переконатися, що ви
зрозуміли весь сенс,
і якщо ви готові послухати,
давайте зробимо це добрий день, пасажири,
це ваш капітан говорить першим, я
хотів би привітати всіх праворуч  крило
політ 86 день ми в  наразі крейсер
на висоті 33 000 футів на
швидкості 400 миль на годину
час становить 13:25.  погода виглядає хорошою,
і коли «Попутний вітер» почався, ми
очікували приземлитися в Лондоні
приблизно на 15 хвилин раніше
запланованого, погода в Лондоні ясна
та сонячна з найвищою температурою 25 градусів
сьогодні вдень погода працює, ми
повинні мати чудовий огляд  Місто, коли
ми спускаємося вниз, бортпроводник прибуде
приблизно через 20 хвилин, щоб запропонувати
ваші легкі закуски та напої, а
невдовзі після цього почнеться фільм на борту польоту
, я поговорю з вами ще раз, перш ніж
досягну пункту призначення, а до цього моменту сидіти
назад розслабтеся і насолоджуйтесь рештою
польоту, добре, тому я знаю, що нам може бути
дуже складно слухати, що
говорить пілот, тому що він говорить
у навушниках, і він розмовляє з
нею через їхній мікрофон, але вам
потрібно лише на траві  цифри, тому слухайте
ще раз і зосередьтесь лише на
цифрах, добре, тому давайте послухаємо ще раз
добрий день, пасажири, це
перший говорить ваш капітан, я хотів би
привітати всіх на правому фланзі  ht 86
день ми зараз пливемо на
висоті 33 000 футів зі швидкістю повітря
400 миль на годину,
час 13:25.  погода виглядає
хорошою, і з «Попутним вітром» на нашому боці
ми очікуємо приземлитися в Лондоні
приблизно на 15 хвилин раніше
запланованого, погода в Лондоні ясна
та сонячна з найвищою температурою 25 градусів,
сьогодні
вдень погода підтримується, ми повинні мати
чудовий вид  міста, коли ми спускаємося
вниз, бортпроводник прибуде приблизно через
20 хвилин, щоб запропонувати вам
легкі закуски та напої, і
незабаром після цього почнеться фільм на борту літака
,
я поговорю з вами ще раз, перш ніж
досягну пункту призначення, поки  потім
розслабтеся та насолоджуйтесь рештою польоту
добре, хлопці, давайте перевіримо, тому я сподіваюся, що ви
отримали всі цифри, давайте подивимося, добрий
день, пасажири, це перший говорить ваш
капітан,
я хотів би привітати всіх з
правого крила рейсу 86 a-  добре, а
швидкість 400 миль на годину досить швидка, добре,
і через попутний вітер з нашого боку
ми очікуємо, що в Лондоні будемо навчатися
приблизно на 15 хвилин раніше
розкладу, це добре, тому погода в
Лондоні близько  Лір і сонячно, і
сьогодні вдень 25 градусів, досить тепло
і сонячно, це справді чудово, і
тому за 20 хвилин ми встигнемо
запропонувати вам легку закуску та напій, а
потім ми будемо зніматися в кіно, і капітан
буде говорити  пізніше, який у
нас був приємний рейс, і ви прибули
в аеропорт,
тому, хлопці, ви вибрали, в який аеропорт ви
прибули, і ви обрали аеропорт Хітроу,
і після того, як ми забрали свій
багаж, ми думаємо про найкращий спосіб
потрапити в центр Лондона
ми знаємо, що таксі дійсно зручне,
але дороге, і ми хочемо спробувати
метро в Лондоні, тому що це
одна з найстаріших підземних систем
у світі, то що б ви обрали, хлопці,
і цього разу ви вибрали метро, а ми
удемо подорожувати за допомогою  цей
транспорт, але перш ніж ми розпочнемо нашу
подорож, нам потрібно отримати трохи словникового запасу,
тому подивіться на трубку, це популярна
назва системи метрополітену,
всі матраци
Тім, ви можете тільки здогадатися, чому вони c  все
це так, можливо, тому, що це виглядає як
фішка або ви можете побачити знак
метро, і це інша назва дл
метро, звісно, ви можете дістатися з аеропорт
на автобусі.  їхати на
таксі ви можете
застрягти в пробці, яка дійсно
неприємна, ви нікуди не поїдете, тому
що є занадто багато автомобілів, трафік
перевантажений, то у вас це слово
зручний зручний означає простий у використанні
добре своєрідний синонім до комфортного, але
все одно  трохи інакше, тоді настає
година пік година пік – це година, коли ви
можете застрягти в заторі,
це найзавантаженіший час дня, коли
всі повертаються додому з роботи, а
на дорозі багато машин, і
так зазвичай буває  вранці
чи вдень чи ввечері
добре, тож тепер давайте подивимося на
розмову, яка могла відбутися
в підпіллі, тож подивіться
фрази, виділені червоним кольором, або фрази, які ви
повинні заповнити  прогалини в діалозі
спершу давайте переглянемо сам діалог
, чорну частину, і там у
нас Фіона та Джон, тому Фіона запитує, тому ми
беремо цю синю лінію, а потім вона отримує
іншу фразу, а ми в
кінці рядка, тому ми  йти на схід на схід
означає, що ми йдемо на схід або на захід,
потім ми йдемо на захід,
тоді вона каже, чи потрібно пересідати на
поїзд, іноді вам потрібно пересідати на
поїзд у метро, щоб дістатися до вашого на
рямку, але я можу пересадитися в Кінгс-Кро
сі, тому  ми обидва можемо вийти разом.
Зійди, значить покинути потяг, тепер
давайте подивимося на прочитані фрази, щоб
моя була пряма, але ви повинні зійти
і змінити мою пряму, щоб
лінія 9 Джона була прямою, але Фіоні
доведеться зійти  і зміни лінію добре,
це приведе нас на схід у місто, а потім на
схід у місто, у нас був синонім,
пов'язаний цікаво добре, а потім ви візьмете
цю чорну лінію, вони знають лінію і
йдіть на північ, щоб ми зрозуміли, що
фіона повинна змінити рядки, так, це називається
Пікаділлі лі  не, але в якому напрямку, щоб
ви могли помітити, що в деяких
запитаннях відсутні деякі допоміжні дієслова, і
це цілком нормально, коли ви
неформально розмовляєте зі своїми друзями,
але, звичайно, письмово ви не можете допомогти з
такими запитаннями, добре, давайте спробуємо
заповнити прогалини  Ну, знайдіть хвилинку і
спробуйте заповнити всі прогалини
[Музика]
[Музика
] ви готові, давайте почнемо, тож давайте прочитаємо,
я Фіона, ви можете закінчити, тому ми візьмемо
цю синю лінію, ваша черга, хлопці, давайте
прикидамося, що ви все ще читаєте я
Так,
це називається лінією Пікаділлі, але в
якому напрямку Фіона каже нам,
що ми в кінці лінії, тож ми
йдемо на
схід, що відповідає Джону під назвою "
Гаразд", це приведе нас на схід у місто,
а потім знову для ваших власних відповідей, чи
є у нас  щоб змінити поїзд і чи не могли б ви
знайти відповідь на це запитання,
і Джон каже, що моє пряме, але ви
повинні вийти і змінити так, і
остання фраза очевидна, тому давайте прочитаємо її,
але я можу змінити її Kings Cross, щоб ми
могли отримати  вимкнено т  ogether, і Джон
відповідає, а потім ви берете цю чорну
лінію, потім ні лінії і йдете на північ, добре,
знайдіть хвилинку, щоб прочитати цей діалог
вголос, щоб потренувати свою вимову
[Музика]
[Музика],
тож тепер у мене є дуже хороша подруга, міс
Ольга,
вона також  викладач англійської мови, і вона
порадила нам зупинитися в цьому прекрасному
готелі поблизу Гайд-парку.
Я думаю, що цей прийомний готель буде
ідеальним житлом для нас в Лондоні
на ці два дні, ми збираємося зупинитися
там і дякую вам, міс Ольга за ваші
рекомендації  тому ми в готелі,
і нам потрібно знати, де щось знаходиться
і що ми можемо використати або куди нам
звернутися, щоб попросити допомоги, тому ми добре тут,
можливо, це не нова для вас кабаре, але
все ж давайте переглянемо, що маємо  у нас є
спальня ванна кімната односпальне
ліжко двоспальне ліжко два односпальні ліжка туалет
прийом душ подушка підйом для рушників та
менеджер дуже прості слова Сподіваюся, у
вас не виникне проблем із ними, тому
приділіть хвилинку та позначте кожну картинку
[Музика]
[  Музика]
добре
, хлопці  давайте перевіримо і напишемо, щоб у
нас був двійник, але зазвичай у нас
це найкраще, коли пара зупиняється в
готелі, тоді друге слово - туалет, а
в туалеті чи у ванній ви можете
знайти рушники, я думаю, що їх має бути
три або  навіть більше, ніж односпальне ліжко,
це погано лише для однієї людини, але ви
можете мати костюм або кімнату для двох, тоді у вас
буде два односпальні ліжка, ці ліжка не
для пари, вони для друзів, тому
ви можете спати окремо, тоді
загальна кімната  називається спальня, це
зрозуміло, тоді ви отримуєте ключі на
стійці реєстрації, і насправді ви можете отримати допомогу
там від менеджера, і, звичайно,
це дуже розкішно, коли у вас є справжня
ванна у ванній, і якщо в
готелі багато поверхів, вам обов'язково
знадобиться ліфт  щоб дістатися до своєї кімнати, і
якщо подушки м'які, ви
добре відпочинете вночі, а потім вранці
ви отримаєте гарний душ, тому я сподіваюся,
що всі слова зрозумілі і ви
вже знаєте їх, давайте продовжимо, давайте
прочитаємо визначення та  т  тоді ви повинні
розповісти нам, що це за слова, тож
перше визначення те, що ви використовували
для висихання після прийняття душу
, безперечно, це рушник, друге
визначення, що об’єкт у спальні, на якому
можуть спати двоє людей, називається великим поганим
двоспальне ліжко наступне
місце в готелі, де ви
заселяєтесь та виписуєтесь, це номер рецепції
для об'єкта в спальні, на якому
може спати лише одна людина, це односпальне
ліжко особа в готелі, яка може
слухати та  вирішувати проблеми клієнтів –
це менеджер номер шість кімната, де
сплять люди, спальня номер сім,
кімната, де люди приймають душ і
чистять зуби, – це ванна кімната номер
вісім, на що ти лягаєш
спати – це подушка, а я
Сподіваюся, це м'яке, тоді номер дев'ять
електронна машина, яка перевозить людей
на інший поверх, - це ліфт, а
машина, яка забезпечує водою, яку ми використовуємо
для миття тіла та волосся, - це душ,
добре, хлопці, давайте продовжимо, тоді це
вранці, і ти встаєш, і ти вибрав
свій сніданок, звичайно, коли ти в
Лондоні, неможливо не їсти повний
англійський сніданок, і, звичайно, ти
вибрав цей сніданок повний англійський, а
не континентальний, і що ти
очікуєш побачити на своїй тарілці  давайте подивимося, щоб
повний англійський сніданок містив
для ковбас, а потім до помідорів помідори значить
нарізати власноруч, потім 300 грамів упакувати міні-
гриби портобелло добре, так що
багато грибів, потім 3 столові ложки
рослинної олії, а потім 8 помідорів добре копченого
бекону 3 скибочки білого хліба, нарізаного  на
трикутники, потім чотири скибочки чорного
пудингу добре на 400 грамах печених бобів
і на середні яйця вільного вигулу, який
величезний сніданок Я думаю, що я можу
вижити, думаю, два дні на цьому
сніданку, але добре великий, можливо,
вам знадобиться друг  щоб з’їсти все і,
звичайно, ви пам’ятаєте урок про
спорт і харчування, який ми провели з Полом,
коли ми говорили про калорії
вуглеводи білки, давайте подивимося
факти харчування для t  він повний англійський
сніданок, тож кожна порція лише однієї
порції забезпечує нам 836 калорій,
що становить майже половину того, що ми повинні
з’їсти в день, тоді ви побачите, що в ньому
дійсно багато жирів, а якщо подивитися на
вуглеводи та білки, це також
дуже багато вуглеводів і
білків, але насправді мало клітковини,
подумайте трохи, і як ви можете налаштувати
цей сніданок до свого раціону, можливо, ви
можете додати більше овочів, щоб отримати більше
клітковини, і, можливо, ви можете зберегти бекон,
але, звичайно, це було б  Це буде
повноцінний англійський сніданок, тому хоча б раз
у житті, якщо ви приїдете до Лондона, спробуйте
його та оціните свою думку,
наступний варіант вам потрібно було вибрати,
де паби або шоу Вест-Енд, і
цікаве сталося, всі
колеги та випускники  вони проголосували
за паби, хлопці, я обіцяю, що одного дня
ми поїдемо в Лондон і проведемо гарний
вечір у пабі, але сьогодні ми підемо на
шоу в Вест-Енді з дітьми,
добре, діти, тож ходімо, і у вас буде
свій лондонський мюзикл  дослідити
Подивіться, що на сцені Лондона багато мюзиклів,
можливо, ви бачили деякі з них
в Інтернеті або чули про них,
і всі вони дійсно блискучі
, чудові та чудові, тож давайте
прочитаємо текст про цей
досвід  дівчина, як вона відвідувала ці шоу,
а ви повинні прочитати текст і
назвати параграфи, хлопці, це дуже легке
завдання,
і у вас буде таке завдання
під час ЗНО, це
завдання дуже легке, і воно може дати вам
кілька  для
пошуку інформації, і іноді ця
інформація дійсно очевидна, давайте
подивимося на назви мюзиклів,
тож перший з них — Lady Miserables, можливо,
це щось пов’язане з Францією, навіть
якщо ви цього не знаєте, тоді приходять Чарлі
та  Шоколадна фабрика дуже відомий
фільм з Джонні Деппом, можливо, ви дивилися
його, щоб зрозуміти, чи, можливо, ви
прочитаєте книгу, тоді приходить мама Мія,
можливо, ваші батьки слухають
таку музику,
і ви чуєте  d щось з них потім
приходить ми ріжемо ми ріжемо зло означає зло
потім приходить Король Лев давайте прочитаємо
текст і назвемо параграфи так це
блог дівчини, як вона переїхала до Лондона,
і вона розповідає нам про свій досвід
про мюзикл, який вона відвідала  тож давайте
прочитаємо, коли я переїхав до Лондона, я відчував, що
я був у раю
всі ці блискучі театри та
мюзикльні плакати всюди
мрія була лише одна проблема, моя англійська
була поганою в той час, ви могли б
подумати, що розуміння англійської не
так важливо для мюзиклів  тому що все, що
вони роблять, це співають і танцюють,
повірте мені, особливо якщо ваш
улюблений - Біллі Елліот, де
акторський склад має дуже сильний акцент з
Ньюкасла, альтернативний розповідь
Чарівника з країни Оз з точки зору
двох головних відьом ABBA і  gelinda,
спів співів і танців просто
захоплюючий, все, що ви хочете
зробити в кінці шоу, це бути зеленим
так зеленим і думати, як Elphaba,
пісня, яка буде  Я застрягаю у твоїй голові
на тиждень, кидаючи виклик гравітації, напевно,
наступний абзац, ми всі знаємо
історію, але мюзикл – це просто ще один
рівень мурашок, ти мені не віриш,
давайте поговоримо про це знову, коли вам
вдасться перестати співати це коло
життя та поведінка жирафа
добре наступне, вам не потрібно
бути шанувальником Abba, щоб насолоджуватися чудовим
білим шоу цього барвистого шоу. Грецький острів із
посиланням на 70-ті закриває захоплюючу музику,
яку ви не зможете зупинити
про вас,
і тут ви, ймовірно, співатимете
Mamma Mia, тут я йду знову приблизно на
тиждень добре, наступний я знаю, я знаю, що
це сумна історія, але повірте мені, ціна настільки
висока, що ви відчуєте, що ви
насправді були частиною  Французька революція
з прапорами та барикадами і все таке,
і якщо ви бачили останній
фільм, то давай, не соромся, я чую, як
ти наспівуєш «О, моя власна», і останній з них,
це шоу оживляє всю магію,
яку ви можете знайти  у книзі Роальда Даля
казкова обстановка  змусить вас забути,
що ви в театрі в центрі Лондона,
і діти. Я не впевнений, що
є слово, щоб описати їхній талант, дотримуйтесь
поради Віллі Вонки, ходіть зі мною, і
ви потрапите у світ чистої
уяви, хлопці.  Я впевнений, що
ви можете назвати всі абзаци, тож
це «Король Лев»
звідки ми знаємо історію, тому що
коло життя я пам’ятаю це з
мультфільму і поводжуся як жираф,
звичайно, це про Саванну,
це про Африку та Лева  King -
це назва цього шоу, наступне
Mamma Mia так, це шоу про грецькі
острови, і є пісні групи ABBA, і
одна з пісень, які я пам'ятаю зі свого
дитинства, - Mamma Mia, я знову іду,
і це очевидний натяк для вас
отримати назву цього шоу, наступна
назва місця — розвалини, і це насправді
французьке слово. Я бачу шар статті,
і я знаю, що це французька мова, а потім у мене
є підказка в тексті «Французька
революція», тому назва мюзиклу
очевидний наступний гл  Арлі і шоколадна
фабрика - це в основному книга Роальда
Даля, і якщо ви читали книгу або
дивилися фільм, то дізналися
б ім'я Віллі Вонка, останній абзац,
який насправді був першим у нашому тексті,
я любив бути останнім, тому що  можливо,
це один із найтовстіших, але ви можете зробити
це так, як я, щоб зробити ті, в яких ви
впевнені, а потім залиште один варіант, який
стане очевидним, тому що у вас є лише
п'ять варіантів і п'ять абзаців, тож
і альтернативний розповідь Чарівника з країни
Оз  це холодні вихідні, тому що зло означає
зло, і коли ми говоримо про відьом, ми
думаємо про злих істот, хлопці, я сподіваюся, що
нам сподобався цей урок, і насправді у
нас є лише один день у Лондоні в
суботу, але у вас є ціла
неділя, а у вас є притулок
Ви ще не досліджували парки, ще не ходили по магазинах,
тому, будь ласка, перейдіть за посиланням і
продовжите подорож, сидячи
з крісла разом із проектом Британія, дізнайтеся
про Лондон Я сподіваюся, що вам
сподобається навіть місяць  добре, хлопці, плануйте свої подорожі,
не соромтеся уявляти все, що вам подобається,
і нехай ваші мрії збуваються,
залишайтеся з нами, щоб повернутися
[Музика]
ви